il ya 7 ans j'ai intégré une école de
cinéma sans connaître la nouvelle vague
il ya trois ans pile poil j'ai monté une
société de production sans savoir ce que
c'était
et il ya un an et demi je me suis
retrouvé dans le bureau d'henry
kissinger sans savoir qui lui il était
en fait pour moi le chemin comprend et
pas forcément celui pour lequel on se
destinait à la base moi je voulais être
cavalière jeunes chevaux mais manque de
bol j'ai eu un accident
je me suis fait renvoyé plusieurs fois
de nom a eu 12 fois pour être très exact
et à cette douzième fois j'ai pris une
décision plutôt radicale à savoir que
j'ai été chercher un certificat de
radiation au secrétariat de mon lycée ce
qui me renvoyaient définitivement du
système scolaire français et je me suis
inscrite au cned les cours par
correspondance
voilà à partir de ce moment là c'était
vraiment génial parce que j'avais mon
rythme le matin je prendrai mon temps
l'après midi je travaillais mes cours et
j'allais au musée et le soir je
dessinais des gogo danseur dans des bars
du mar 2
voilà donc au milieu de mon analyse
terme de terminale en fait au cned
l'insouciance est passé il a fallu que
je me trouve un métier une fois j'étais
plutôt créative en fait je faisais du
dessin comme vous avez pu magnifiquement
le contre était de la musique de l'art
du théâtre et de la danse
donc je me cherchais un métier plutôt
manuel et créatif
donc en fait c'est sur un petit dépliant
de bts que j'ai découvert la production
de films il y avait écrit qu'il fallait
être plutôt vif plutôt dynamique et
débrouillard et avoir une sensibilité
artistique
tout ça c'était complètement neuf pour
moi parce que dans ma famille la
production de films les médias personne
ne travaillait dedans et personne ne
connaissait vraiment donc c'était
complètement inconnu dès les premiers
mois de ma formation je me suis dit que
ce serait intéressant de me confronter
au terrain et j'ai intégré l'équipe
d'une société de production en
alternance là bas j'ai travaillé sur des
fictions télé du magazine et c'était
super enrichissant en fait parce que ce
que j'apprenais à l'école prenait enfin
du sens concrètement sur le terrain
quand j'étais au bureau très très vite
j'ai su que j'avais vraiment trouvé
un métier qui me plaisait avec allait
devenir le métier que je fais
aujourd'hui après trois ans passés dans
cette société
je dois vous avouer que je commençais un
petit peu à m'ennuyer et j'avais comme
une espèce devant un terme qui me
disaient mais tu as des projets thaddée
propre tu as tes propres idées donc
essaie de te lancer fait quelque chose
fin en patois du truc et du coup bah
j'ai monté ma boîte
voilà comme ça sans vraiment trop me
poser de questions mais mon état
d'esprit globalement à cette époque
c'est que tout était possible
d'ailleurs j'en suis toujours
complètement convaincu aujourd'hui j'ai
un côté un peu bisounours c'est
d'ailleurs le surnom que m'a donné ma
grand mère quand j'étais tout petit
mais comme j'ai monté ma voix je me suis
dit bon bah voilà j'ai des super projet
j'ai une équipe au top donc forcément
tout le monde va vouloir qu'on fasse ses
films bon je dois vous avouer que la
réalité elle est complètement différente
il suffit pas de prendre son téléphone
est de passer un coup tu un coup de fil
à une chaîne pour avoir un financement
il faut vraiment se battront donc du
coup bah j'ai construit une petite arme
ramon bizanos et puis je me suis acharné
jusqu'à ce que ça finisse par payer
je connaissais pas grand monde dans le
milieu donc je signais en fait entre une
espèce d'euphorie totale quand je lisais
mes premiers scripts et que je faisais
des retours à mes auteurs et une panique
intégral quand il fallait que je prenne
mon téléphone pour appeler une chaîne de
télévision et pour prendre rendez vous
d'ailleurs je me souviens que pour mon
premier rendez vous avec une chaîne de
télé j'étais tellement paniqué que avant
le rendez vous je me disais bon
qu'est-ce que je mais qu'est-ce que
j'emporte qu'est ce que je vais raconter
ça d'hommes et j'avais mis dans mon sac
à main tout un tas de trucs absurde
jusqu'à mettre une calculatrice en me
disant que on savait jamais ça pouvait
m'être très utile mais finalement pour
moi la panique ça va juste être la
seconde avant de se lancer
à ce moment là je me souviens qu'il ya
une petite phrase qui est venu qui était
au pire qu'est ce qui m'arrive bien au
pire les jambes d'iran non et cette
phrase a vraiment changé ma vie
globalement c'était comme de retirer les
petites roulettes d'un vélo on n'avance
pas forcément très droit on se cogne on
tombe mais on se relève et puis on
remonte sur le vélo parce que faire du
vélo sans un petit trou c'est vraiment
trop cool donc voila moi j'ai fait tout
ça je suis tombé j'ai avancé de travers
je me suis cognée mai
pense que si je devais recommencer je
referai troussant absolument rien
changer en 2012 un concours de
circonstances va faire que je me
retrouvais avec le script d'un
documentaire sur la guerre du vietnam
voilà lamy qui me le fais pas c'est en
fait il est super enthousiaste himdi
tuor faustine c'est absolument génial
ils ont même prévu d'interviewer henry
kissinger
je peux vous l'avouer aujourd'hui
aussitôt remonté à mon bureau je vais
sur google et je tape henry kissinger
voilà donc tout ça pour dire que je
maîtrise absolument pas le sujet que
l'histoire allait très très complexe et
qu on est très très loin des fictions et
des magazines télé sur lesquels j'ai eu
l'habitude de travailler pendant ma
formation
mais je vais être vraiment tenté par ce
nouveau terrain de jeu et ce
documentaire va représenter pas loin de
deux ans de travail donc de deux ans de
ma vie
donc pendant deux ans avec mon équipe on
line comme objectif principal de faire
un beau film qui soit didactique et
novateur on n'avait vraiment pas envie
de faire un énième film sur la guerre du
vietnam
on avait envie de raconter l'histoire
autrement d'aller déterrer ce qu'il
pouvait vraiment enrichir le public a au
départ il faut passer il faut savoir que
on parle vraiment de zéro on a pas
d'image on n'a pas de fond on n'a pas
darchy vous n'a juste quelques lignes
posées sur un cahier
nous on a choisi de parler de la
diplomatie secrète des échanges qui ont
eu lieu en france à choisy-le-roi
notamment à choisy-le-roi entre les ducs
tôt et henry kissinger savoir que ces
deux hommes en fait on négocier la paix
au vietnam dans des pavillons de
banlieue parisienne ce qui est juste
incroyable
ce qui m'amuse beaucoup aujourd'hui
c'est que ce que vous voyez derrière
derrière moi c'est ce à quoi ressemblait
mon film il ya un an et demi et je vais
vous laisser découvrir quelques images
de ce qu'il est devenu
choisy le roi
dans cette rue tranquille à une demi
heure de paris les quelques retraités
qui l'habite sont intrigués
ils n'ont d'yeux que pour une ville au
numéro 11 dans la plus grande discrétion
à l'abri des volets clos deux hommes se
font face
encore aujourd'hui personne ne sait que
les centaines d'heures de leurs
entretiens ont été enregistrés plus elle
fait tout les oppose
leur culture leur idéologie leur
parcours ils sont en guerre comment
vont-ils faire la paix enfin écouter
souhaitant que ça s'arrange pour le
mieux cette histoire de guerre qui
commence à être fort longue
je dois vous avouer que c'est
complètement magique en fait parce que
ces deux ans de travail ils prennent
justement tout leur sens quand le film
il est terminé
ce film j'ai dû le voir des centaines de
fois pendant qu'on travaillait dessus
sur le montage sur l'étalonnage sur le
mixage mais le plus beau moment je pense
que c'est quand je les regarde et finit
projeté dans une salle de cinéma
en ce moment j'ai pas loin de 22 projets
dont 20 projets de documentaires aussi
un long métrage et on est en train de
monter aussi un festival de cultures
urbaines y est voilà vous avez des
j'avais des images de choses qu'on a
faites ces dernières années en fait
quand j'ai monté ali sopra qui signifie
prendre de la hauteur
j'ai choisi d'utiliser pour faire mon
logo une image de pélican qu'est celle
ci que vous voyez que j'ai que j'ai
prise au venezuela en fait au venezuela
j'observais des pélicans s'envoler et je
vous voyez tout ce qui est un pélican
c'est un oiseau quand même très très
lourd assez disgracieux quand il est au
sol et quand il va s'envoler on a
l'impression qu'il y arrivera absolument
jamais mais de kiel après un petit peu
de hauteur justement il a un vol qui est
très majestueux y vole en banc et il
peut voler des heures sans se fatiguer
donc je trouvais que l'image était
plutôt joli donc en fait pour moi
entreprendre c'est exactement comme fer
le pélican à mon sens pour pouvoir être
un bon entrepreneur il faut aussi se
mettre d sacré coup de pied au derrière
et accepter de faire face même quand
c'est vraiment vraiment pas cool et en
ça pour moi en fait entreprendre c'est
une terre inconnue au quotidien parce
qu'on doit à la fois ancré ses rêves et
sa vision en respectant les principes on
va dire de fonctionnement traditionnel
de la société et des entreprises
mais il faut aussi savoir s'adapter et
se réinventer et entreprendre en réalité
c'est presque une folie on a l'air
on a l'air complètement bizarre quand on
suit ses rêves et ses idées comment est
ce que je ferai quand je serai grande
est ce que je suis raisonnable c'est des
questions qui peuvent vous paraître
étrange mais sont des questions sincère
on grandit tous tous les jours mais
quand on a une entreprise elle grandit
avec nous en fait vous me regardez vous
devez sûrement vous dire que pour vous
je n'ai que 25 ans mais en fait de mon
point de vue c'est l'averse de mon point
de vue j'ai déjà 25 ans et g
dû produire à peine 1 % des films dans
lesquels géant enfin que j'ai envie de
faire et en lesquelles je crois et je
vis en fait avec l'idée que quand on
fait pas les choses les bars on part
avec donc ma course en fait c'est de
produire tous les films justement à
lesquels je crois vraiment très fort et
j'ai fondé alice oprah avec cette envie
donc travailler sur des sujets
différemment et les développer et les
faire exister
je vois mon métier comme une profession
vraiment turbulente on est à la fois
dans un métier qui est très généreux et
qui est dans le partage mais c'est un
métier qui sera toujours turbulent et
toujours généreux avec mon équipe on a
essayé de se façonner une entreprise à
notre image on essaye de travailler dans
la joie
on travaille en fait complètement dans
la joie je suis convaincu qu'on peut
entreprendre en restant léger en étant
heureux est vraiment joyeux on passe
notre journée à faire des blagues et au
bout de trois blagues
il ya une bonne idée qui sort mais je
cultive vraiment pas la différence pour
le plaisir d'être singulière mais plutôt
pour proposer une autre vision et je
pense qu'avec une autre vision on peut
faire bouger les cadres on peut proposer
du contenu différent et le faire évoluer
le transformer et en fait moi si je
produis du média je pense que je suis
aussi là pour inciter au débat que ce
soit dans des toutes petites salles
comme on a pu le faire l'année dernière
au creusot ou à arcueil américain public
un petit public beaucoup plus petit goût
mais nos films en fait l'idée c'est
qu'on les fait aussi pour que pour qu'il
y ait des gens qui les regardent donc
que ce soit dans des collèges dans des
lycées sur internet je sais pas sur
votre téléphone portable
nos films ils sont vraiment fait pour
être vu en fait et nous l'idée c'est que
on voulait transmet on vous transmet des
projets sur lesquels on a fait en sorte
qu'ils aient du contenu qui tiennent
vraiment la route et on espère que vous
allez nous écrire que vous allez à votre
tour nous bousculer en fait nous poser
des questions interagir avec ce que vous
avez vu et j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui on a de plus en plus
besoin de justement de ces échanges pour
s'enrichir mutuellement et pour
continuer à se questionner ensemble
voilà donc en fait tout ça va c'est
l'histoire de mon hasard à moi
d'un petit bout de papier qui est devenu
finalement devenu ma vocation
en fait je suis venu vous dire que vous
avez le plus grand pouvoir
votre plus grand pouvoir c'est de
choisir la personne que vous êtes et il
faut surtout que vous vous souveniez que
pour monter un projet et c'est ce que je
suis venu vous vous démontrez vous
n'avez pas besoin d'avoir un réseau vous
n'avez pas besoin d'avoir une fortune
personnelle
vous avez absolument pas besoin
d'accumuler d'été aude et les
connaissances théoriques pendant dix ans
vous n'avez pas besoin d'adieu
vous avez juste besoin d'être oui alors
j'ai pas fini
vous n'avez besoin d'être absolument
rien d'autre que la personne que vous
êtes tous déjà voilà